we think that the pandemic really just
dumped some gasoline on the Mental
Health crisis in young people Jake Ernst
hears from young people regularly about
the challenges they now face after
covid-19 changed the world I am really
concerned about the decline in
friendship right now overall kids are
just having less and less connections
Canadian researchers are also concerned
about Trends they are seeing in
emergency room visits for young people
more kids are struggling now than they
were before the pandemic clinical
psychologist Dr Sherry Madigan and her
team looked at data from 18 countries
comparing numbers of er visits from
before the pandemic and then during up
to July 2021 while there was a 32
percent decrease in Pediatric ER visits
for any health related reason during the
pandemic there was a 22 percent increase
in Children and adolescents going to
emergency departments for suicide
attempts and an eight percent increase
in visits for suicide ideation there's
research just suggest that only about a
third of them get any type of services
after they leave the emergency
department there are also challenges for
long-term support about a quarter of
kids who go to the emergency department
for a suicide attempt will actually go
back to the emergency department within
six months for a similar mental health
concern while a recent study suggested
the effect of the pandemic on global
mental health was relatively limited
that study focused on clinical data and
did not have fulsome data on children so
we had data and Adolescence but
virtually none on children so Under 12
years old but experts say that kids
spent more time alone and some studies
indicate screen time doubled we are
seeing a lot of kids just go inward when
we don't have practice when we don't
have exposure to practice as it maps on
just with the current Global Climate I
think it's really decreasing their
ability to handle and become resilient
in the face of stress Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto